okay four people joining our live stream
this is part of a push to get functions
for wolf language version 12 finished
and we are looking at geo functionality
okay so new core framework yes so we
have seen this already the main thing
here was to upgrade your image and your
elevation data to be as powerful as your
graphics so they have many new options
now those all on the pages and things
yes okay
but when you say aspect ratio of the
image are we saying some other doesn't
distort the image right that the final
result is a square so this is the aspect
ratio of the projected map we never we
never distort the maps unless it is
through the projection we never collapse
that are squished because the XS are
incorrect now right but should we say
that it's pretty obvious I mean so long
as you give an example to do what many
people requested which is I won't
exactly Square month and that was quite
difficult to obtain the gia range
because your instinct takes into account
the curvature so absolutely exactly
square so so you see that that map of
Cuba is exactly same one that it has
been extended maybe we should say aspect
ratio of the image area or something or
aspect ratio of the of the displayed geo
region yes of the region the image
perhaps me aspect ratio is well it's
ultimately for the image right exactly
yeah that's that's why I would like to
keep image if possible there so the
helper of the helps of the displayed
image projected image perhaps it will be
because what we are stressing here is
that it is the final projected image and
not the original G arranged what is
controlled by this why don't we say that
yeah that's fine that's what you just
told me
exactly umm now how can I be a
background-color yes imagine that we
have the world in the bone projection
did you can try that if you want set
your image of world okay background
color yes for point out well let's see
what we say outside the region specified
by the projection it's outside the wall
it's just outside the world so that our
maps will always try to add as much as
possible but if they find the border of
the world then they have to use their
background right well do we say that
somewhere else do we have in Geographics
do we have a way of saying this in
Geographics we do have also our own well
in Geographics we document the geo
options and then we say it also takes
the graphics options which is one of
these yeah background
um by the way model of the earth to use
it's not just the earth it's not the
earth yes it's probably yes and the fact
here we say that birth or other body um
do we need to fix that someplace else by
the way I will tuck it down because your
mother is used in many places innovation
they turned on the do a function why is
this hanging here
that's not a good sign dear oh dear I'm
trying to save that file so and this is
hanging for some reason oh come on what
is happening here well that's not a good
sign
boom we will have to check whether this
worked correctly
okay how long okay
all right so we were looking at
Geographics and geo image two of the
changes we made survive
okay I wondered survived okay let's hope
this file wasn't corrupted in some
horrible way um okay so background color
outside the projection
I would prefer outside there but the
world outside yeah outside the world
it's just a really weird thing to say if
I might say so um I mean the projection
is not something geometric that you can
be insight outside the projected
coordinate system outside the predict is
not yeah that's a good one
that's good okay okay
why is restr sighs was it not an
exercise here because in its eyes you
can control both independently in this
function in its eyes is what you will
see roster size is how many pixels the
image actually has and we should say
pixel dimensions of the result pixels
let's see em exercise yes so that system
that image size and when do if I press
the size automatic it takes the image
size okay um but they can be specified
independently dimensions of raster for
the data or something underlying data
okay so this is that okay random geo
position so that is analogous to random
point exactly it's kind of cool actually
we use it a lot for examples and now the
statistics group is very happy with this
ones any reason to keep it experimental
I don't see it why did this happen
new and dollar ember do we know that
should be can you can you get someone to
track that down
this is pretty nice
okay and it has back pointers from Jeff
from Adam point probably not I typically
don't touch the geometry functions but
yeah I think it should go I think it
should go there
what's that under for you yeah well you
think it should go that's far down
inside all right okay fine
random geo position um
okay actually this should prolly point
to random variate as well okay all right
well
supercool okay new options yes so these
are the new four options that were
motivated in mainly by generation data
so looks fine to me
mm-hmm yeah this is quite useful to get
final control in the production oh gosh
the stupid park again know what that is
it's very since in the cartoons this is
very similar to what we've talked about
before now when you talk about
directions here what are the what is the
meaning of a direction it's in the Geo
grid it's in the Jade grid grid
directions presumably exactly okay
that's all good cheer resolution
there was an armrest Oh sighs so size is
number of pixels resolution is distance
between pixels physical distance between
pixels Sergeyev resolution is equivalent
to assume level not to a raster okay so
there are multiple ways of specifying
the final thing for example if you give
the Geo grid range and the jurist
resolution you will know how many pixels
you are asking for so if I might say so
you have mentioned your grid range here
it should be yeah um that looks fine to
me
now what about geo array size but what's
that that's yet another version of this
the array size is the alternative to
raster size for those cases in which the
output is an array and not an image
should we not mention geo array size
here yes
okay so see also for Jo so that we want
to see geo resolution
well raster size cure a solution then
what and you its range gia range okay
now so geo array size is now an option
in geo elevation data for example yes
and in fact it's the only function that
currently has that but I'm going to try
to export it to the geo magnetic model
data excellent
so you see how many new options this one
cut what does that mean geo model of
locations so we want to use the more
consistent yes I think this because the
elevation data takes two types of input
it takes the range of region input and
then it also takes a Geo position array
and returns an array of respective
elevations nothing I had that second
model in mind but but yes we should be
consistent with the other ones
okay oh don't tell me this is gonna hang
again what is going on here so we should
obviously report this this is probably
some problem that the had turned her
branch build oh gosh this is really
frustrating
no of no great note at least oh wait a
minute know it now it finally did it
it's really weird something is wrong
though okay new extraction methods yes
so this is also something that has been
requested easy ways to extract more
information from your position objects
yeah it's a good idea so now they have
methods and it's quite flexible you can
even extract for example not longitude
and latitude reversed because sometimes
you need them in that order in Exeter
very nice very nice um you know what
else we should have is latitude quantity
or something so that you can extract it
in degrees
um it's a bit long lassitude longitude
quantity is really long but I think it's
okay so we have this two DMS string
thing right
yes it's called DMS string and it can
take you directly at your position you
can do DMS string of here
you can control the position with a
second right and you think yeah decimal
degrees right mmm what do you mean well
how do I get decimal degrees but with a
degree with with degrees by the way I
saw recently maybe yesterday in some
situation I saw a map designation that
said NS in the II W
have you seen that undo we parse that
this no horrible mess where did I see
that that was a map designation Oh ice
for some place um so you mean if it had
a sign it would still say minus 40 and
yes that's right I see yeah I know I'm
trying to remember where I just saw it
uh let's see
gosh where did I just see that um I'd
see trying to find this
you
Oh hold on a second
um
I'm not sure okay any case um I guess
that's a note for the interpretation
stuff um I'm trying to remember where I
just saw this uh uh just yesterday what
was I looking at um okay anyway I don't
remember all right let's let's go back
here so now this is for geo position
right so if I go to the Geo position
function examples I don't think I've
added a note for this sardar on our live
stream says that in the geocaching world
i'm good about geocaching in ages um
that people write coordinates like for
example this I wonder whether we parse
that
magnificent well I would say that wasn't
a huge problem unless unless those are
these is this a correct parse 53°
oh that must be 13 minutes yeah yeah
this is right all good right we're in
good shape down okay let's look at your
position oh so you didn't you don't have
a table of these yet I see I was
thinking of adding a note perhaps but I
would add a table of all these things
that you can do okay yeah I'm done young
open actually to add more like if you
have fat your position array something
that reports how many points do you have
insides and things in that yeah what's
it gonna do if there's multiple things
in the Jaro position here what do you
mean if if there
the Geo position has you know many date
objects there are many points I see yes
it's an array so it's returns one for
each one okay uh okay so well you're
awfully gonna put this
[Music]
so we're gonna say geo position got
taught of prop gives the specified
property of a Geo position possible
properties include and then we can give
at the end the the multi case I don't
know why this didn't show up as a red
thing that's really odd that's probably
to do with that atom version nonsense
that we just saw so I think here we just
need to give this this big long list
right um fine uh so there are respective
properties for therefore J position
heads yes so we should copy this with
some the specification into all of those
and show ya obviously we should show the
examples of what what happens here maybe
even one of them in basic examples I see
I have an example in scope I would give
one in basic examples cuz nobody knows
it's there okay
you know I hate the fact that that time
information is an absolute time thing
yeah we have this discussion of you
remember that before it was years but of
course because years are not equal in
size
you know that's even more horrifying I
mean it could be a data object could it
be a data object well I want this to be
well it's not possible once we have
reels big names of a big number
well they have to be because I was they
don't know what that one is right
because it has too many digits to be a
machine precision yes but yes I think
the thing is that when the opposition
has an array of points they need
numerous AI system a single your
position is kept as a big number
just in case the position is useful for
something okay the alternative here is
to use some notion of year which is
continuous in size like for example
bacilli and year or Julian year which is
what astronomers use I think that will
be reasonable but I mean how on earth
committees and regulate that now well it
was years until version ten but it was
the wrong notion of years and then we
changed to these in order to make it
more precise as the second since 1900 or
what this is seconds yes since 1900 in
you in in in in each time okay
so that the abuse in for example
julienned years is that we use a
counting of years which is exactly
365.25 days yes I understand
is there any standard for this in the in
the Geo world or and how will this
relate to a stroke position exactly
that's that's my worry in the Geo world
because most of the computations don't
need a very high precision of years they
use years and they don't worry very much
but I want this to be precise so that we
can use satellite positions and in the
future we can go yeah but we're gonna
get messed up with Julian years if
somebody sees something that says 1993
there but it was actually 1995 because
of the you know leap year being off or
something it's gonna get super confusing
yes it can't get confusion so what the
streamers do is that they use Julian's
years with respect to for example now
they are using year 2000 and I guess in
2050 50 they will change to 2050 so that
error is effectively small there's a
hack it is but it works for them so for
up for around 50 or more years
it works why do I think of the y2k
problem yes always have to say Julian
tears with respect to yay mm right okay
so listen this is something we're
probably gonna want to change which we
get Astro position really ramped up but
nothing for right now okay so grid X yes
so when we are working with the Geo grid
position for example I want to stress
that you are extracting grid coordinates
and that's why I put great in front of
all of them seems reasonable to me and
then we have geo displacement which
which has now here we can do this
exactly the same thing I remember we
have polar notation so the first one is
distance the second one is direction and
then we also accept changes in LA
which I'm calling assent and even
changes in time but there are
differences in time so I'm calling it
delay so what do you think I don't like
that very much I think we should call it
elevation change instead of us scent a
scent is too cutesy in my view let's
just call it elevation change and time
change time time difference time
difference what sorry what did we say
elevation change why don't we say
elevation difference
our version difference time difference
okay are we on to the stuff now yep okay
so first there is a diagram to
understand what's going on here this is
taken by one of the standards books in
projections so we start with the earth
and then we approximate by a by the
datum sorry I have too many details just
in case we have to look at understand
I'm just trying to get us out to Walter
yeah so we start with the with the earth
which is the earth with mountains and
everything and then we approximate it
with a datum surface which is an
ellipsoid and it has the proper size so
this is the correct sizing miles so then
we go to something that typically is
called the generating globe which is
another surface but it can be much
smaller in our language we call it the
reference model so right the datum we
typically call the Geo model and the
generating love we call the reference
model and then from the reference model
we go to the map be a projection and
then in the first step there are no
changes in scale that the Earth or the
datum they have the same scale in my
thing so geo model is what we've been
using to represent the datum yes exactly
yeah so the model is like a
generalization of the concept of data
because we can say your mother goes to
Pluto or goes to Mars okay so what we
don't have is the Geo reference model
which is this third level here we do
have it it's an option of the projection
so we always encode that in the
projection itself so a parameter of the
projection go to the projection data or
here yeah yes so you see the reference
model it's one of the parameters they
are in I see yes and that there is what
we say the size of the reference model
and then the map is of the same size of
the reference model but distorted and
that's why geo scale the scale problems
always have these two parts the nominal
scale which is the ratio between the
datum and the generating globe or the
reference column and then the distortion
introduced by the map projection okay
okay so the the idea is that for a given
point of the map or a given point of the
earth we want to know what would be the
final change in scale of these two
things combined and the the standard way
of expressing this was always the size
of things on the map divided by the
original size of things on the earth yes
and this is this is why the map say 1 :
a hundred thousand but of course this
means that when we are we working with
maps which are very large like 1 column
1 million they did the cartographers
called that small scale which is very
confusing but and another
in fact correct because that one to a
million is not because the thing is not
distance preserving the projection is
not distance preserving that claim about
the scale will be true in some
particular place right so when they give
their the nominal scale one to a million
that's typically referring to the first
step from the datum to their reference
model then the distortion is always
assumed to be something of order one or
but that depends on the point okay what
on earth history Oh distance scale me in
here yes so this distance alistun skills
means that for Mercator at the location
of Copenhagen and if we go in the
direction north east or south direction
45 then what's happening here is that in
the marked sorry in in the in the on the
earth divided by the distance on the map
we have this quotient so for us the maps
always have dimensionless coordinates so
I divide by I sorry I lost something
here too right that what was the what
was the right shoulder it was distance
on earth divided by distance on the map
if you open the page of the a distance
scale I have a better example there's
somebody on a live stream is asking
about eclipses in finite speed of light
you should read the blog the long
elaborate blog post that I wrote last
summer about the total solar eclipse you
know any place where there's that much
text to explain what it is is a scary
thing okay so here is the same example
so we have that push that supposition on
Copenhagen and a unit of the map in the
sense that if you see that the ticks on
the map it's twelve point five to
thirteen point five
that's a unit alright that's a real grid
position I see that's leave that is on
the Geo grid yes so the question is
what's the distance corresponding to one
unit of the map
that's the 38th month so if we had to
express one of these nominal scales we
would have to say or it's one inch to
this number of inches how do we put that
scale on a real scale bar right so the
scale bar is able to put the barn there
and it will yes yes right now.just scale
bar goes to automatic puts both metric
and imperial I'm trying to convince
bread that it should be only the one
that is determined by dollar unit system
yes even more confusingly one could have
a map of a part of the earth that one is
not currently in but I think what it
should be well one is currently in that
determines the unit type right because
that's there that's the unit's you are
used to yes
okay so yes so the summary is your scale
your distance scale gives you the scale
of a unit of mass distance and it takes
into account all the factors involved
there I understand but this goes with
Geo scale bar yes yes your distance
scale now we mentioned distance because
there's another one for terrible by the
way it feels scale bar better be
mentioned here geo area scale which is
the very same thing for areas
so okay it's local ratio
money we say between actual Jo distance
[Music]
okay what is this in terms of like like
metric tensors and things is there an
easy statement of it yes so this is
related to a product of the metric in
the jacobians this gives symmetric
matrix which is that is so ellipse and
then these things are determined by the
eigenvalues of that matrix can we
generate with our lips then yes right
now I'm not exposing it directly I have
an example if you go to the section in I
think it's plication or obscure distance
kiss olives and these things yeah sorry
I've been determined by the distance
scale function so the distance scale is
basically is it's like like the distance
from the center to that ellipse and I'm
putting there the minimum and maximum I
mean realistically Brett should have
something which represents like if you
plug in the stress tensor right there is
a representation of this best stress
tensor at every point in terms of
ellipses that's something that is like
like brett has vector plots he could
have you know tensor ellipse plots
basically yes it's like a symmetric
matrix plus yeah you should
just that because that's the
generalization if who wants to show
distortion on the earth we would do it
by having instead of having a bunch of
vectors which would show I mean you know
that will show vector flow on the earth
we could show a bunch of ellipses on the
earth yes they see way to do that for us
is to use JA disks so there in the end
this this ellipses and that being like
your disks I see I see I see
yeah I've seen those pictures right we
have a bunch of G of disks a different
term I don't even know how to generate I
mean there's a somewhat annoying
I mean geo range isn't what you think it
is so to speak gia range is the plot
range analog I mean there's a different
thing which will be to put a geo grid to
generate a grid on the earth I mean
that's an interesting thing to think
about is how would you generate a grid
which is where you know like you're
laying down roads 10 miles apart and
he's generating grid of roads that's
that's the Geo grid lines so yes open
debates of geo grid lines I think that's
what you are referring to yes
and these are always parallels and
meridians in any projection okay and
then we have the grid lines that would
put a grid on the projected okay all
right so the question is Jiro doesn't
scale yes so to me the simplest way to
understand this is that when you have a
paper map and it says 1/2 a million you
understand it is one inch to a million
inches or things like that but when we
have a map on the screen what do we mean
we don't have a natural size for the map
then I think it should be one peak of
the map goes to so many miles I find the
word scale really confusing here
what the heck really is it it is the
ratio of the real distance yes to the
map distance right I mean it's geo
distance per unit tick exactly
um inflation differential construction
this can be used for example to
integrate lengths to lengths using
projected objects via an integrated
insula grid relative GL distance it's
kind of weird well the complicated
concept because the issue is that it's
an infinitesimal thing but it's divisor
is a great big you know unit distance on
the grid alright so what will we call
this I mean this is like a um you know
it's like you say miles per hour but you
don't spend a whole hour you know you
don't have to see how far it went in a
whole hour so what is well what about
things like that crazy I don't know what
quite what it means this is the distance
element isn't it it is similar to that
it feels related so the distance element
would be the metric yes and and then
this is some sort of projected version
of the metric
there is also something generic like geo
distance distortion I don't think that's
a good idea it's not a distortion it's a
number I mean it's the it's not
Distortion
it's only distortion if you're making it
you know if you're changing it right
that it's going to take a projection so
this is in a sense a description of the
projection property of the projection at
that point hey how about this geo grid
distance scale because of the Geo grid
it is the distance scale of the Geo grid
so you take the geogrid in unit you know
it's the units of the geogrid and then
you ask what is the scale of 1 unit on
the geogrid right and it's true though
because it's a quotient what we are
returning is at your distance so it's
like the ideal distance of the geogrid
distance but maybe it's just geogrid
distance geogrid unit distance is it
that it says what the unit distance on
the geogrid actually corresponds to
Mercator defines a geogrid yes yes yes I
think that this could be explained in
the following way okay gives okay I'm
going to try it here
okay gives the actual Geo distance
corresponding to a single to a unit
distance to the unit distance on the Geo
grid with projection obtained first once
the unit distance on the Geo grid at
location
well I think this basic statement gives
the actual Geo distance correspond to a
unit distance to the unit distance to a
unit distance at location lock on the
Geo grid corresponding to projection
proj at location lock intersection in
the direction alpha right we have a
question from the livestream do you go
over the mountain peaks no geo distance
has defined as the geodesic distance on
the on the datum
the euro distance on the geogrid
obtained with projection proj
um how about something like this the
thing I'm missing here is either the
word local or the world limit okay
perhaps the limit gives the limit of off
and then we keep everything because the
actual distance correspond to a unit
distance on the yai let's tell me to say
I think it evaluated as go ahead if we
just say gives the limit of it should
work gives the limit of the actual Jo
distance right someone on our live
stream is pointing out that this might
not work for oddly shaped asteroids we
are well aware this is assuming a a Geo
data model that is fundamentally an
ellipsoid and yes it is complicated
enough with that and yes we have
considered the possibility of other
shaped objects represented by other
datums and it is fascinating but
extremely complicated and the theory of
geodesics on arbitrarily curved surfaces
is a complicated subject
um someone is asking what's easiest
ready to find the angle between two geo
pause there's a there's a function to
that isn't there the angle between two
geo paths
well we would have to start by finding
the crossing point we don't have that
yet so if you have the the crossing
point how do you find the crossing point
of two lines specified geometrically I
think we are
added a function for that I guess it's
free Jung intersection something like
that but slightly grotesque but to ask
that question do you mean if you have
the formulas how do you mean no no if
you have the line objects cause the line
objects yeah I would guess it's free
channel intersection
okay but so you're saying so if we have
the crossing point then it's very easy
because it's just a matter of finding
the bearing of that crossing point to
the next point of the you pass for one
and another struct in the angles so
that's otherwise known as geo bearing or
geo direction direction exactly okay
and now the next question being asked is
we've given three geo locations that
spherical trigonometry it's a spherical
triangle um I don't think we've yet
dealt with spherical triangles and a
nice clean way heavily well it's
possible to do all the operations if we
just specify a spherical datum that's
possible and then it's pure its faculty
so so spherical trigonometry is a
particular case of ellipsoidal geometry
which is what we do right but I mean in
the ellipsoidal case well clearly in the
spherical case it doesn't matter where
you are whereas in the ellipsoid case it
matters if you're on the equator or of
the poles and so on right what I mean is
that we we can describe those
differences and we can have a polygon of
three points or three your positions and
it will do that right but I mean the
current geometry the region stuff does
not yet work on curved space spaces
right and right yes you would have to
create a 2d surface which is curved
itself and then do computations on that
surface right I understand but all the
stuff with regions could in principle
work I mean we have talked about
spherical position and so on we haven't
implemented that yet have we but that
was the plan is in addition to having a
Geo position to have a spherical
position yes I mean I know Roger
eventually will attack French a
geometric ASIS or right but I think I
mean that the basic point there once we
have spherical position specified in
spherical coordinates
then you know that is somewhat
generalizable to other
ellipsoids by the time we have bizarre
shaped asteroids or you know space times
and things then it gets even more
complicated so the simplifying thing
India is that we always know we have an
ellipsoid if we go to general surfaces
it's it's full blown differential right
the question about what the region is a
section takes geo path objects which I
bet it does not right now but it
probably should yes so something
important is to establish a bridge
between Geo and geometry and now with
the new polygons one the new polygons
with holes you're working on that's
going to be a lot easier and I'm hoping
that we can establish the tradition
right because the whole the polygons
with holes are relevant for geo type
polygons
yeah does that solve a problem of the
South Pole or not no that's an
independent thing but so what we need is
a notion of polygons which is more in
more powerful than the one we have so
right now the polygons of Geo position
is basically assuming that there are no
issues of the sort for example once you
have a path on the earth it doesn't
establish one polygon it gives to you
need to know which of the two sides of
the path when if you say the polygon of
the equator which I'm is really flat
right so we need a new notion of
polygons that will be at your polygon
based on the polygons with holes that
knows on which side of the path you are
complicated okay it's complicated yes uh
okay all right so let's let's agree on
geo geo grid unit distance do we agree
about projected projected unit your
distance so my only way I like this this
suggestion but I'm still worried about
what the users will expect the output of
this to be a geogrid a distance or a
distance so somehow that the fully
correct thing would be something like
geogrid unit geo distance and now you
know you take a geogrid thing and you
output a Geo distance but it sounds too
long well but also you're trying to
I think I think this is okay jogo do
distance I think explaining it this way
you know what I don't think we should
set a limit here I think this makes it
very confusing I think we should put the
limit in different place gives the
actual Geo distance correspond to a unit
distance tendeth projection evaluated in
the limit okay in the limit of
approaching location look from
directional farm it's not from we got
the sign wrong then um these are going
to be positive in both directions but
okay or in the limit of leaving location
lock in directional something okay
evaluated in the limit of infinitesimal
I wouldn't say infinite as you know I
think in the limit of moving from of
this place this
we have dear displacements or perhaps
these the limit of small displacement
yes exactly
from location lock in directional okay
okay all right we can do the rename here
okay geogrid unit distance okay should
we leave this experimental or should we
just make it um well what the function
does is pretty well-defined the only
thing which was problematic is the name
so alright now the second line I'm not
sure whether to force the users to write
min max as third argument and then they
can do max or mean things like that what
do you think sorry for this last thing
here yes so perhaps we can have three
arguments always and and if the users
won't mean max they should write comma
min max I think they should write common
max yeah because it gives more
flexibility of writing now mean max and
right I don't think that's right for
that okay so there is yes so they
Spanish I have to simplify all of this
right well hopefully the new name will
help I think so okay so cheered a
geogrid unit area same deal
exactly it's the same thing I was a call
before G oh dear arrey asking
all right I can also transfer the
description yeah wait spent the whole
I'm just getting the satisfaction of
changing the name um
chill gradient area oh great
okay I'm digitize and then there's a
third one oh no oh yes which is the
direction so the three things we are
always worried our distance area and
direction and currently I was calling
these but but not now we have they were
to call it I was calling it geo
direction Distortion
but now it has to be agreed unit well
it's not you know we could call it the
agreed Direction difference because not
now yes yes that's right
geo great Direction difference its
difference between the directions on the
Geo grid and the directions on the earth
exactly if two directions were
originally perpendicular and now they
are not it will give you the difference
by which they are not perpendicular okay
alright so that's getting renamed
geogrid direction difference okay then
we'll do future eyes and you'll fix up
to the details of this exactly okay
great and and then we have the vector
families the vector objects so these are
like cow scenes of the opposition's and
they have exactly the same structure
like therefore do position objects so
they are the four do vector objects and
because they are geometric vectors they
always need to know where they are so
the structure is location a row vector
and a vector is specified as length M
bearing alpha so but thats related to
your displacement isn't it it's it's
it's a different concept of very related
yes okay we should call it the same
thing just common offer I think here
well but it's not a dist wait for
example imagine that we have a vector
which is a velocity and acceleration of
people so that's why I mean I'm being
very general insane modulus only I think
you could tell like but for for vectors
we don't say length we say norm or
modules I think length I mean would you
say a length of so many miles per hour
sighs
sighs okay okay but but basically this
is a vector yes it's a vector which is
defined by its norm or size and the
angle with respect to North that's the
vector and then you can have the zero
vector in do object which we do can give
three projections to the E and you axis
Y and then you have the zero vector X Y
C in which you also have three
projections but now you're projecting on
the axis of the earth so that's good for
example to compare vectors in different
positions because you are converting
them into 3d vectors so women if you
want to know for a plane so you're gonna
give the instantaneous velocity vector
of a plane and different places right
exactly and you need to know which
frames you are using for example
typically do respect that it will be
given with respect to north and then if
you are given a ten miles per hour or
100 miles per hour and 30 degrees it's
your vector but if you are saying if you
are given 550 miles per hour worth north
60 miles per hour East then it's a
vector in you some live stream is
pointing out the obvious name for this
is magnitude of the vector yes yes that
sometimes do we avoid magnitude because
seems to represent quantity this can be
numbers but this magnitude is fine yes
yeah bearing is hardly the guess a
direction you can say I see as news
these are the three names direction will
be fine it's as a direction is a bit
more us after the first would use more i
I think bearing is right because
relative to North here right I think we
could get away with same magnitude here
and then I don't have to change this and
indeed um okay so let's imagine you're
doing a solo are we going to generate
for the wind for example exactly end
it's a very them so what happens so
perhaps the example further long refers
into a reference page so wind data and
what is this incredibly ugly object here
so so that's that's a dart so that's a
dart and a circle and it's representing
there I think it's precisely wind
direction can you go a bit up yeah but
but did we get graphic design to look at
this because it looks horrible well
let's do that please yes yes so yes do
you have their window vector data and it
returns you can ask for a director
directly and gives their magnitude and
the bearing fifty degrees okay okay so
then so if I want to integrate for
example over you know the plane you know
I don't know what that means
okay so if the plane is in a certain
bearing relative to the I'm so confused
um so the important thing is that people
can now specify vectors just by giving
our bearing for example and
in every projection they will have the
correct orientation that's what that's
what I'm trying to represent in there
right I have to disappear actually now
um but I think we've made good progress
here and I guess tomorrow we have some
stuff with geo vector plot exactly
tomorrow fine I will push all these
changes and thanks to folks on the
livestream and see y'all soon